[Music]
this masturbatory logo spewing keeps
going on and on week after week
most shows cut down their opening
credits after a few episodes but this is
just the [ __ ] logo crawl
this kind of display is the equivalent
of the ubu dog barking at us every week
for 30 full seconds
make it stop if you end up with this
much toothpaste sauce outside your mouth
you're simply toothpasting wrong
oh yes i remember all those early aught
family sitcoms that had a close-up of
the neighbor's ass in the opening
credits
halloween's a magical holiday halloween
episode's in february where's your
costume tommy this is my costume
i'm the cool twin costume slackers
that's orgasaurus rex
not a real dinosaur the dorkasaurus
racks would fit right in the middle of
tv
sins mixing your rubiks with your jenga
everyone knows competitive jingx wasn't
invented until 2014.
he's your uncle why would i be scared
because it's four o'clock in the
afternoon you're secretly afraid he's a
vampire but why would they think that
pietro is a vampire if he's able to
sleep in a room full of sunshine
unharmed i think
kids
[Applause]
to be fair i'll take a fish over a
toothbrush or those weird brown and
orange wrapped candies
that's not exactly how i remember it
except according to your own look before
cutting to it you
are the one remembering it if this was
pietro's memory why did we cut from your
blatant memory face
you probably suppressed a lot of the
trauma we've already mentioned the fun
marvel winks the easter egg teasing the
incredible design work and the acting
that make these homages such a success
but have we talked about how incredibly
they continue to layer in the themes of
trauma and denial it allows the show to
maintain both
surface frivolity and meaningful depth
and damn it i'm about to give another
sin back aren't i
and he's what you call a man-child
finger quoting words that don't
need them also licking your fingers ever
again
ever you are incorrigible darling i know
you have a secret thing for mexican
wrestlers this sexual tension is leading
somewhere right like they certainly
wouldn't build this up every single
episode and then not give us some sort
of payoff
wait is the final episode of homage to
californication is it
where to keep your water balloons who
asked the question this way wouldn't you
just simply ask where do you keep your
balloons
who stores balloons with water already
in them pietro's tattoo
looks like it says mom but i think it
says hom which we all know stands for
house of m which is of course a
reference to
house of mouse in the mickey mouse
clubhouse so hot dog hot dog here's a
hot diggity sin for yet more pointless
disney synergy
and which one of you is the sassy best
friend it's funny because it's true
i haven't seen disney's cell phone this
hard since cars 3 ended up trying to
teach a lesson about crass commercialism
god help me i'm going to talk about the
timing again because this tv shows the
first portion of the episode we are
currently watching even though in the
real world this meeting appears to be
the same night as the drone attack
so is this episode happening now for the
first time and if so why aren't they all
watching it for clues
and if not how are the events
intersecting when it's mid-afternoon on
tv and still
night here i feel like you just want the
episodes playing on the random tvs as
filler but no one has given a single
consideration to the process of how
and when these episodes air all you
people who left
still have the luxury of optimism
you have no idea what it was like what
it took to keep the lights on
then maybe you should have told her all
about this instead of just sending her
on a mission her first day back
maybe it's a good thing you weren't here
when your mother died
because clearly you don't have the
stomach for this job here's the thing
i'm okay with hayward turning out to be
a bad guy but this is the guy who was
doing
everything he could just a few episodes
ago to get rambo out of the wanda sitcom
world and is now willing to shuck her
aside so he can play war
i'm just saying a little growth of the
character would have been excellent why
didn't anyone tell me the plan
the better question is how did anyone
have time to tell anyone the plan
convenient sward ponchos are convenient
look i know you want me to pronounce it
differently but you're not the boss of
me now and you're not so big
life is unfair trick-or-treating in the
daytime kick-ass
yeah you know yet another marvel movie
property that has both
aaron taylor johnson and evan peters
what does it all mean
all the canyon has disappeared stealing
and now the jack-o-lanterns have been
smashed vandalism
now everyone's covered in silly strings
and bullying it's the rare how to turn
your characters from likable to [ __ ]
trifecta
sorry what i gotta bounce to where
exactly at least some of that
went down right where herb is standing
this show got intensely dark
it's like they took the dread of get out
but took the laser accurate social
commentary about racism in america and
replaced it with
um sitcom superhero stuff so
yay i've seen plenty of creepy things in
this job but this kid's left thumbnail
is flat out the most horrific thing in
the history of human existence
it hurts to even look at it make it go
away pretending that the face decomposes
at a different rate than the rest of the
body
marquee refuses to indicate if we are
lindsay lohanning or haley milzing
also in this universe who even voices
frozone they've got
full-sized candy bars a few blocks up
mom can we go
next stop cavity town i mean it's cool
in all that tommy has super speed but
he was only able to grab two candy bars
lame
oh how cute these kids went for
halloween as ruth bader ginsburg in the
current american justice system
totes adorbs this cul-de-sac has the
most extended driveways in the history
of sac bottoms that's just poor city
planning why even have a cul-de-sac in
the first place
oh no one leaves wanda won't even let us
think about it
but wanda will let you think about
thinking about
leaving my way back into the hex will be
here in an hour
just gotta meet my guy over the ridge
you know at some point this tantric
pronoun gaming could just be considered
audience abuse just tell us it's reed
richards so we can climax already
worst case scenario wanda removes my
free will and puts me in ultra low rise
jeans
right that's what i was thinking worst
case scenario
keyword has your blood work there are a
thousand different files i could be
looking at right now but i happen to be
looking at your blood work on the off
chance you may make a declaration
about wanting to travel into the hex
again the energy inside has rewritten
your cells
on a molecular level twice it's changing
you
like i don't know mutating them just say
it marvel
say it hey
i'm not some stranger obvious cover-up
lie is obvious
hayward you sneaky bastard giving your
secret file the designation of eyes only
and then attaching your name to it
we know that this city is several miles
around but thankfully for the plot
vision decided to emerge right by the
main outpost
and within short walking distance from
the server farm where darcy has been
hacking unhindered all night
are they showing night of the living
dead in this town square sure it's a
great choice because it's public domain
and all but now i have to know who's
controlling this so i know why their
movie choices are so on the nose
a metaphorical representation of disney
engulfing fox somehow makes it into the
show
want to hang out with us on a live
stream we don't care if you're on the
toilet in your mom's basement or in the
broom closet just put on some deodorant
and join us during sin week
2021 march 22nd through 26th we'll
release
three extra sends videos and go live
four times to hang out with you all you
have to do is become a sin club member
at patreon.com
cinemasins do it now that way you're the
first to learn about our evil plans
and if you join today you have time to
watch over 70 exclusive videos and
podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd
[Music]
halloween's a magical holiday all about
family
friends and the thrill of getting to be
someone else for a day
wrong don't you know what happens on
halloween
you are incorrigible darling i know you
have a secret thing for mexican
wrestlers sometimes you wear stretchy
pants
in your room he's for fun i smell dino
success
really cause i smell baked crotch can
balls fart because i feel like i'm
smelling that too
right on little dude whoa you must have
been booking how fast do you think you
were
going i am locutous
aboard resistance
is futile
only i didn't say fudge i said the
word